[Musica]
e se tifo per i cali di stili più
sufficiente uffizio navigation
explaining calde si sparò ovest e poi ti
sto palloncini blu ed escort di ballard
manson drammatico timer presentation in
rosso anche gli inning med presentation
in otto bank a negozi e video videoclip
di sale mensa di application store
insite andai kate wright ifi coach
concluso il polso di techno liberi buon
vino
andai che incide con crisi da una grande
emozione nella fredda arhus in danimarca
il 5 dicembre nel 2018 in un lampo
passano 40 anni della mia vita
li ricordo tutti la prima immagine è
un'immagine dolorosa in 23 novembre del
1980 90 secondi che sconvolgono il paese
90 secondi che sconvolgono l'irpinia 90
secondi di terremoto terribile tremila
morti dove vina feriti 280.000 sfollati
parto tre giorni dopo il terremoto
vado nell'epicentro a teora e vedo
confusione non c'era la protezione
civile
c'era ancora confusione
vedo morti vedo tante bare e ancora
spesso lo ricordo un odore terribile che
mi è rimasto e lo sento ancora dentro un
odore di calce un odore di disinfettante
una grande confusione una cosa enorme ma
vedo anche molta speranza
molta gente che si mette in moto e da
questa immagine
poi ricordo che la caritas italiana e la
carta della caritas della mia città
decide di stare un anno un anno in quel
in quel luogo dove la comunità si era
sfibrata dove bisognava ricostruire
tutto un anno che a me è cambiato la
vita mi ha cambiato la vita a tante
persone ha cambiato la vita a tanti miei
amici e un po questi volti di questi
miei amici sono quelli che in qualche
modo che hanno fatto un pezzo di strada
con me sono quelli che in qualche modo
mi hanno aiutato anche ad andare avanti
passano altri anni ricordo a 30 anni di
impegnarmi nel movimento di volontariato
italiano una grande organizzazione ne
diventò anche presidente nazionale
in quell'occasione capisco grazie a
questi volti
grazie a queste pensieri grazie a tanti
testimoni
capisco che il volontariato non è solo
fare qualcosa
il volontariato è anche impegnarsi
affinché in quella terra d'irpinia si
costruisce baglioni diversa perché fosse
i morti sarebbero stati molto meno vuol
dire impegnarsi per cambiare le leggi
vuol dire impegnarsi perché ognuno
faccia il suo pezzo di strada
questo è quello che mi rimane di questo
volontariato di tutti questi anni e
quindi mi riporta immediatamente a quel
5 dicembre del 2018
in quell'occasione commosso non sapevo
più cosa dire ma le cose che sono
riuscito a dire sono pochissime e ho
detto a tutti
che forse il futuro il futuro non è di
chi costruisce muri perché i modi la
storia ce lo dice ce lo dice benissimo
di mori non ne stanno in piedi mai prima
o poi muri cadono e questo è stato il
sogno di padova capitale
ero riuscito a convincere il sindaco di
padova di candidare la città perché se
non delle cose belle 6.500 associazioni
solo nella provincia di padova fanno
delle cose magnifiche dito sindaco siamo
pronti a candidarci lo convinco e
insieme candidiamo la città e abbiamo
vinto una grande festa 7 febbraio del
2000 e 25.000 persone a festeggiare
questo anno di padova capitale
il presidente della repubblica un grande
onore per l'italia per la nostra città e
per l'europa
una festa magnifica ma non era solo per
far festa al volontariato e per dare un
testimone a questo volontariato un
volontariato che dice ricostruiamo
insieme il paese
ripetiamo e ricuciamo questo paese
ma la festa è durata poco siamo arrivati
a fine mese a fine di febbraio
e i primi malati di co vita anche nel
nostro territorio
e poi si è preso tutto le nostre città e
anche la mia città era silenziosa
silenzio buio pochissimi potevano
muoversi e da questa cosa
abbiamo capito che la capitale doveva
essere un'altra cosa e siamo diventati
un grande laboratorio a cielo aperto
dove 1800 giovani volontari si sono
messi a disposizione per cambiare la
città per aiutare chi era in difficoltà
per fare in modo che chi era nel buio o
non arriva a fine mese potessero trovare
una risposta è stato un laboratorio
incredibile nella mia vita è la prima
volta che ho potuto vedere
una grande un grande giacimento di
solidarietà che si è messo in moto
ecco questo questo segno magnifico di
solidarietà ci fa capire che forse la
strada è un'altra e abbiamo capito che
forse è giunto il momento di mettere
degli occhiali diversi sono gli occhiali
del volontariato sono gli occhiali che
ti permettono di vedere cose che altri
non vedono quando metti questi occhiali
ti cambia la vita
molti ne hanno già messi ma molti altri
devono ancora metterli questi occhiali
ti fanno capire che forse bisogna
impegnarsi in maniera diversa che il
futuro dello sviluppo e un altro passerà
il covip forse avremmo bisogno ancora di
muoverci come volontari in maniera molto
forte
speriamo di no passera ma se non
cambiamo il modo anche di sviluppare se
non cambiamo il modo di pensare
probabilmente ci sarà bisogno fra
qualche anno ci saranno anche altre cose
e quindi forse è giunto il momento di
fare un'altra ad avere un'altra
strategia e forse con questi occhiali è
possibile vedere un modo diverso le cose
e forse con questi occhiali è probabile
che l'uscita di sicurezza al futuro è
per noi possibile perché il futuro ha
bisogno di un modo diverso di pensare
ecco io penso che questa sia la grande
scommessa che abbiamo in qualche modo
cercato con padova capitale
cambiamo il nostro sviluppo cambiamo il
nostro modo di pensare
cambiamo anche la politica e con questi
occhiali questo è possibile
io ve li voglio offrire e agri aspetto
tutti a lavorare con me grazie
[Musica]